hi I'm a Greg Alba and I'm Brianna white
Brianna white came over today bitching
at me about how I haven't seen the
Uncharted 4 story trailer yet and I was
like why are you bitching at me you
haven't seen yet either and then we were
like whoa we should film a reaction to
this then that is how the story began of
how we are here
true stories is that how you make
friends with women you call them [ __ ]
but I don't call you what I can call you
a [ __ ] I said no I said Brianna way
bitching him right that's a great herb
to you I didn't call you a [ __ ] right I
would never call you a [ __ ] it's not
won't see white rose weird you know it's
a good thing I'm really excited to watch
them and wrote a poor story trailer
because this guy move on
alright good transition charter for Xbox
please we were meant for this Nathan
you me together
we would guest
for something great
those who prove worthy paradise awaits
took a long time for him to get out of
this game he's meant for this life last
I checked we're all a bunch of thieves
digging around what we should turn off
his outside yeah I'm a man of fortune
and I'm a Sikh my
sure
are you ready to seek your fortune
what is your fate
I made a promise that I was done with
this life how long we've been chasing
this thing long time really long time
just you and me
no offense these guys they don't get it
if you're done lying to me thing he
should stop run to yourself
biggest pirate treasure of all time is
within our grasp
look Nate I'm gonna make you a one-time
offer drop everything
go home
live your life while we can just end it
right here who's got a bit on the way
and you on this
you
ever wonder like different choices how
we might ended up no I like the hand
we've been don't little world huh wait
what release date 27th April
ps4 for the players no that's an old
release date for what her uncharted it
said release date April 27 that's not
better fact check that before you get
super excited May 10th
right that's it that's an old release
date I'm gonna make a disclaimer
I've never completed any of these games
I just uh completed and then you have
started them and then I I like when I
have a friend who plays it I'm like I
love this game can i play but I've never
actually bought the games myself and
played it that's why you're here that's
why she do your self she's a save
actually filling in and play these games
I'm going to do yourself the favor I
really like it injury truly an adventure
like they have this really amazing way
of taking you through these sequences of
just pure like heart pounding action you
know it's either a chase scene or an
escape scene or like a scene where
you're almost drowning like it's amazing
like it is so every single moment is
completely action-packed and it's
completely um is is servicing the story
at every point it's an amazing amazing
series Wow and it looks like from this
trailer it's going to do the exact same
thing with uncharted 4 I think that
uncharted 3 did a better job of the
actual action sequences that uncharted 2
did but the story in uncharted 2 was
just a little bit more nuanced had a
little bit more depth a little bit more
mystery behind it so I'm really hoping
that Naughty Dog takes the hint and
merges these two these two features
together really well and uncharted 4 I'm
really hoping that they do a good job I
I am right there with rights whoo Matz
you're like you speak you could be a
preacher but really speaking what I'm
feeling video game is amazing
connecting with me right now that's
awesome um I just feel like the most
exciting thing about this trailer is
showing all the different locales
because that's something uncharted 2 and
uncharted 3 did really well is they eat
they took you into a different place
every four or five chapters or so and
I'm really hoping that that keeps you
engaged in this story because at the end
of the day he's really just a treasure
hunter right I mean obviously he's more
than that but at the end of the day it's
based off Indiana Jones we're looking
for a treasure so I think what keeps us
engaged even though we have one singular
objective every game is we get to visit
these new unique locales with these
amazing vistas which uncharted 3 did an
amazing job of I can't tell really if I
if I like the the singular objective or
if I like something with a little bit
more mystery so in uncharted 3 he was
like our mission is to find this
Atlantis of the sands right and they
found it and that was their mission but
in uncharted 2 they were like oh well we
need to find this stone but really it
turns out that that's not what they were
looking for the whole time they were
looking for something else and it became
about this bigger thing not just about
the stone and so I'm really hoping that
uncharted 4 again plays the balance
between those two things because I want
to stay focused I want to have the
mission I want to know what my objective
is but I also want to be surprised you
know yeah yeah I get you I've done a lot
of thinking about this this is hey I
your observation skills are like armed
par with mine when it comes to the
Uncharted franchise exactly I noticed
you got like some type of erotic thrill
in this girl okay so Elena right so they
have this eternal will they won't date
scenario so an uncharted like Ross and
Rachel pretty much yeah like the were
they they obviously like love each other
and they're like star-crossed lovers and
they're meant to be together right but
Drake just has this passion for you know
adventure and for the thrill of the
treasure hunt and he can't fully commit
to his relationship with Elena and so
she kind of you know reasonably takes
the best of that and she's like look if
you're going to continue to risk your
life I can't be on board with that and
so they have this consistent like
tension-filled relationship and it just
they do such a good job of making your
heart soar every time they look at each
other and it's really sweet and I'm very
excited because it ended really well
between them at the end of uncharted 3
so I'm I'm nervous okay see what kind of
throws they'll be in for uncharted 4 but
at the same time it looks like there's
going to be just enough of that but not
too much but just enough you know it's
it sounds like that these two really
need to just find themselves and it
sounds like they're taking their
insecurities out on each other I feel
like you know if they were just willing
to accept more of themselves they would
be able to accept each other otherwise
you know this is just something that's
just not meant to be and maybe in the
end they could just be friends um I
think I think this might have to do it
drinks upbringing though cuz he really
wasn't as close with his father's he
would have liked him and his mother too
so he has attachment issues you know and
with her you know her dad was very
abusive so she's attracted to people who
are emotionally unavailable and that
happened you know what they actually
haven't gone into elena's backstory that
much so I would be very interested well
if you're very mean well no because they
they gave a lot of Drake's backstory and
uncharted 3 but they didn't give a lot
of a leader I've never given a lot of my
Elena's backstory was that accurate yeah
hell yeah well I mean Drake was pretty
much an orphan
who's raised by his hold you feel
emotionally neglected by his biological
parents well yeah that's why he uses
humor to disguise all of his pain I know
he's like Chandler Bing I have managed
to connect all of them to the cast of
friends I'm really excited for uncharted
4 I don't know if you guys can tell I'm
super excited I think that this trailer
shows that they're on the right track I
just hope they keep on it and then I
really hope that it turns out that they
end up doing an uncharted movie and then
I just want to play on land I like
that's all I really want fine who would
you want to be drink Drake well I it's
gonna be hard to find a perfect Drake
was there were some rumors that Mark
Wahlberg was gonna be playing Nathan
Drake and I was like no thank you
no no III like Marky Mark but now
see I just feel like he doesn't have
that same like sharp wit that way on the
end agenda like Paul Giamatti has I feel
like Paul Giamatti would be a great
choice for drink you know what Paul
Giamatti man no we're like a JK Simmons
where do you get off saying these things
are you talking about you like a Jack
Nicholson type like nowadays overweight
older more experienced you know who
really would be a perfect Nathan Drake
like athlete like 30 years ago
maybe not 30 years ago twenty years ago
Harrison Ford yeah this was based off
Indiana Jones and he Tom Solon really
nailed that that's sort of like roguish
like devil witty personality kinda like
me right you should play me all right is
that everything you wish to express
about uncharted um there's one more
thing that I really want he there was a
image of him swimming past a sunken
pirate ship I remember that I need that
to be its own thing I need that to be a
good portion of uncharted 4 because I
just feel like I'm swimming yes or any
sort of like underwater searching or
adventuring or anything like that just
because I feel like they hinted at it at
uncharted 3 where he was swimming in the
water and he could dive for five seconds
but I just felt a little bit cheated
because I felt like whoa this would be
such a cool thing they introduced the
idea of maybe scuba gear and then we
didn't get any of that I know I really
thought she knew you oh my god cheated
is the word I would use exactly so I
really feel like I need a little bit of
Drake underwater adventuring please yes
he needs we explore that pirate ship
it's all I want
it's basic common sense for the true
fans of Uncharted exactly mm-hmm and
mermaids I think the level would work if
they didn't like the Donkey Kong Super
Nintendo version where you know like you
have to go in the water but you just go
up and down because you're trying to get
to that fish with the long
look fish swordfish same thing yeah see
anything that's all you got to do is
just go above it and then banish
complete the lights now you're back on
when now you're back on land perfection
Diddy Kong
he was always fast but you know he
wasn't like I'm not strong well this
video is wrapping itself up yeah if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today and become a reject it'll be worth
your time and mine
Breanna White has a gaming channel
clearly she likes me okay you are just
finishing up our let's play of uncharted
3 in excitement for uncharted 4 we are
gonna be doing posting some let's place
of that as soon as they come out so look
out for that I'm a tenth she could check
it out pretty excited
I liked her singing voice there what
singing voice uncharted when did I do
that well you said something else just
now yeah you got so excited and you went
you started seeing oh I guess that just
happens not me knowing it I have no
control
yes remain kind of annoying you do it on
the daily casual conversation one time
you do I was crying you're talking to me
okay but you can see that you enjoyed it
and then like bash it like that well you
don't like it are you done I thought
like okay if I say it I might actually
like it cuz I could trick my brain
truth is Wow it's got to go what's got
to go wow it is an uncharted territory
Wow
you know what maybe you shouldn't be so
afraid to change him I'm not afraid
change nothing wrong with some uncharted
territory I be I believe you got a you
know grow and step outside of your
comfort zone all right
yeah it's pretty nice you'll sing okay